en allant effectivement dans les régions
dans les départements on nous rendent en
outre-mer également eh bien nous voulons
mettre l'accent sur la dimension qui
n'est pas uniquement scientifique mais
la dimension humaine de la commission
entrer en relation avec le public avec
les victimes pourquoi c'est d'abord pour
rendre compte de ce qu'on fait c'est
pour répondre à toutes les questions que
les gens peuvent se poser catholiques ou
non catholiques toute personne de bonne
volonté qui voit que l'église catholique
est résolu à se saisir à bras le corps
de ces questions nous voulons à la fois
répondre aux questions du public et d'un
public qui ne soit pas exclusivement le
public parisien et francilien la france
et 95 départements plus l'outre-mer et
donc il faut pas oublier la quasi
totalité des départements métropolitains
et ultra marins et puis nous voulons
aussi rencontré des victimes et qui pour
différentes raisons en raison de leur
âge de leur handicap ne peuvent pas se
déplacer à paris